called order the health and human
services oversight committee meeting for
friday march
25th
2022 would the
clerk please
take attendance
present here representative
here representative mcmahon here
representative murphy here senator guida
is not here senator rosenwald is not
here
mckay is filling in he said for anybody
and given his experience he can do it
so he's our designated hitter for today
we'll look at the minutes from last
meeting which was as you remember two
months ago because of the
snow out a month ago
um
i have several
additions i would like to make to the
minutes i've alerted the clerk as to
this
[Music]
at the very bottom of the first page
review of complaints about nashua
children's home
if you go over to the next page
the name listed is david viliati and
[Music]
anyone
trying to remember who he was this
should be listed
who he was
relating to
nashua children's
home
and
you can see how important this is to me
because i've already forgotten i think
he's something like an executive
director or some kind of a director
i'm seeing nodding executive director
thank you
yes
of nashua children's home
he also
says here um
contrasted the report that was presented
to us
and the credentialing report and if
somebody could supply a sentence as to
what he said
in terms of the differences
he said they were different
anybody remember
mr chair i i i just remember that he
took issue with the official report and
he
in general
he thought it was
incomplete or
may have been an error in some of their
interpretation of the facts
okay
and i don't i wish i remembered more
than that but again two busy months
understood
are we using mics today yeah i am
i would thank you commissioner
sorry um the executive director brought
uh forward the
the point that
the child advocates uh
report was very different than the
credentialing report that they had just
received from their national
accreditation body
and that the
child advocate report was done off-site
and that the credentialing report
actually
required that a team of people went in
into the facility to to observe and
interview the uh the kids and the staff
at the facility so
my recollection is that he was uh just
comparing the differences between those
two reports
we wouldn't want to have an oversight in
a minute
um
also bob keating
this question raised as to whether he
was a is a former staff member
uh
represent counselor edwards
i keep calling you representative
do not take that as prophetic
um for the record john williams the
director of legislative affairs for the
department of health and services and it
was brought to my attention to provide
to the committee through mr villardi uh
that the mr keaton uh introduced himself
as a former staff member so if at a
minimum i think the the minutes that he
would be suggesting at least to bring to
your attention would be to after mr
keating's name to add introduced as a
former staff member uh it was
represented that he's actually a
contractor and not an employee of the
children's home
an independent contractor hired thank
you
do we have names
more names from megan and stacy these
were
free
former staff members
anything else that we should probably
add to this because if we spent quite a
bit of time on it and
uh
this the minutes are not in uh are not
incorrect saying mariah o'neil is the
child advocate it's just that her
replacement has now been hired
um
[Music]
need to be addressed
okay
with this with these
changes
made
thank you
then uh do we have a motion to accept
the minutes with the changes
i move with it we accept the minutes as
uh we just discussed changes
representative edwards moves and
second
representative soloway all in favor
opposed thank you very much
commissioners report
good morning um lori shibanek
commissioner of health and human
services due to time constraints i'm
going to defer my commissioner's report
to our behavioral health report
and have
katja foxx come up and do that report
with me unless there are specific
questions from the committee that they
would like answer about any area of the
department
representative edwards
thank you for coming
[Music]
we you and i had a sidebar conversation
maybe six months ago and you had made a
comment that you were considering
conducting an after-action review on the
departmental
department's handling of the whole covid
crisis putting on
sure so the after action review is
actually being led by the department of
safety homeland security their rfp for
that service there's going to be a third
party that that's going to do it that
rfp went out last week that
that
they will award that that uh contract in
the coming weeks and then it will begin
i do believe it will be a long process
probably greater than a year there were
different phases of our response you
know the first being the ppe and the
immediate and then other phases after
that um and so so
they will go through those phases
there's a lot of requirements for
in-person interviews for unified command
and the leadership team many of those
people unified command the people that
were the three people that were in
unified command two of the three me
being the third the other two have
retired
and are no longer working in those areas
so they will have to go out and find
those people and do those interviews
any further questions now before we hear
the report
yes senator
thank you good morning commissioner good
morning are there places in the state
and where
that people can still get free pcr tests
yes um the pharmacies being
a big one your pcp office um
but the pharmacies being the the big one
that that's doing a lot still doing a
lot of testing so either it is covered
through um your health insurance or it's
covered through hersa
follow up so
but
if it recovered through your health
insurance it probably wouldn't be free
right you don't have a copay there's no
copay for it not that's true if you went
to your physician as well you wouldn't
have to pay
it depends on if you're just going for
the test itself or if you're going for
an appointment so if you go for an
appointment because you have a
respiratory illness and the physician
does a test and the evaluation then
you're going to get a copay for that
visit okay many hospitals have just
drive through clinics and if you call
your pcp office and ask for a covet test
you may be referred to the drive-through
clinic in that case you will not have a
a co-pay for that service and the
pharmacies that's true as well yes thank
you yep
anyone else
representative soloway
thank you mr chairman commissioner nice
to see you again um i just want to point
out for the committee that at our last
meeting in january
you uh presaged what the head of the cdc
dr welinski told us last week which is
that the data system that we're getting
out of cdc is not very useful
you were quite accurate in that regard
do we have anything in place to deal
with a potential surge in the ba2
variant i believe we're looking at about
10 percent um
prevalence here in new hampshire
currently and seasonal influenza
yes so so we are we do have funds set
aside for the fall specifically october
through march we expect that we're going
to see a surge in covid
during normal influenza a normal
respiratory illness season so we do have
our money set aside to be able to stand
up services again if needed um the the
game changer is the antiviral that's on
the market right now and uh
they're readily available at pharmacies
across the state so the hope is that
even if the ba2 variant increases the
the amount of cases in in new hampshire
we're going to have a very early
treatment that you can take at home
without needing to engage the health
care system
with the exception of your pcp but yes
we do have the funding and the plan
available to stand up uh
a vaccine clinic if needed but our our
hope is that the health care system will
take care of
children ages six months through four
years and if there is an additional
booster that comes this fall
that will be as far as we know right now
only for the elderly and
immunocompromised
that will also be handled by the health
care system if something happens that
the surge is larger than we expect we
always have the ability to stand up
state testing state vaccine
national guard assistance things like
that
thank you so much
anyone else yes representative edwards
um so i i was really glad to hear that
we're working on the uh the veterans
campus near franklin
and uh ultimately
uh
who in the executive department i mean
other than the governor uh who is
accountable
for uh developing the plan and executing
the plan for that campus is it the tag
is it dhhs is it who's ultimately
responsible it's not dhhs
it's
it's the tag
my team my team tells me
just so this is just a comment i i don't
know if long term that's the right
organizational structure i don't know
what the right organizational structure
is but i i hope there's further
discussion on that
are you prepared to give reasons why you
think others might be
the better choice
uh thank you mr chair i just in general
the array of services that are going to
be provided through there
to include
addressing homelessness addressing some
kind of a retreat environment
to i assume primarily for ptsd folks
there's probably you know
ultimately going to be some vocational
training in there there's it's it's such
a wide array of services
that i
wonder aloud if the tag who's
responsible for keeping our national
guard
deployable for war
should be spending
so much time focused on kind of a
caregiving
set of responsibilities
the the department routinely
collaborates with veterans affairs and
tag on any type of mental health health
care homelessness we have programs
throughout the department where there is
a collaboration so i'm not concerned at
all
that even if the tag is leading the
project that we will be involved either
through mou or through service provider
through our contracts
but they are leading the project project
but you're right with all of the health
care needs of the people that are
involved i do expect dhhs or our service
providers to be involved
my question is to see if there is at
this point an update which there may not
be
but anything further to report on
payment in lieu of taxes for hampstead
hospital
i don't see melissa here i can tell you
we had our meeting with
the town and we settled on a number we
settled on a one-year contract so we can
update it in 12 months to see what the
impact of the hospital will be on the
town um i have not seen the mou come
forward to governor and council so it's
either it's somewhere in that pipeline
i'll have to check it out i was supposed
to be at that meeting and did not get an
invitation so thank you
yes senator thank you
um
could you give us an update on the
status
of negotiations with cms on maybe that
clawback penalty payment
for the
idn waiver
we had a well not we henry lipman our
medicaid director had a meeting with cms
leadership approximately two or three
weeks ago
they were going to meet internally and
then come back to us
with another meeting date to have the
discussion i think that there is very
much
a understanding that
what what resulted in a lack of budget
neutrality in the state under around the
11 15 waiver number one the waiver
itself there was a flawed design in the
very early stages of it and number two
a lot of the the issues that resulted in
a lack of budget neutrality were outside
of our control mainly being the opioid
epidemic um you know we we went into
crisis in this state probably one of the
worst in our country and then covet uh
so both of those played into the our the
inability to to get to budget neutrality
and uh they they definitely they're
definitely showing an understanding for
that we asked uh
well over a year ago
actually before i became commissioner so
it's well over two years ago to adjust
the budget neutrality
assumptions
based on the waiver and
those conversations are still happening
two years later and we asked for
clarification
um back under commissioner myers and the
pandemic just put everything on hold so
we're back at the negotiating table we
don't know
what the outcome is going to be at this
point
now behavioral health strategy and
10-year mental health plan progress
update
i believe it looks like this of all the
handouts we've got yes
so i'm just going to make some
introductory remarks and then i'm going
to hand it over to kacha unfortunately
i'm going to have to leave after this
presentation to attend another meeting
so
the
behavioral health work in new hampshire
most of you know that it's been
it's been 10 years in the in the making
we've had an er boarding list for at
least 10 years i think we're probably at
11 at this point at this point
we've had a strategy for the past number
of years on correcting this system and
you've seen that this work being done
first through the 10-year mental health
plan which
many of our legislators were involved in
second was really taking a hard look at
new hampshire hospital and how they
operated and i spent
almost three years there trying to
create operationally efficient systems
and in that time frame we saw our wait
list drop by about 50 percent
once those two things were done and even
when i was at the hospital several
legislators and several committees asked
me do we need more inpatient beds and i
was very direct in my answer to that to
say i don't know because at that point i
did not know if we needed more inpatient
beds because i was still in the process
of trying to move new hampshire hospital
in a way to be more operationally
efficient
so now
fast forward about four or five years
later i do know that we that we do need
more inpatient beds and i think we need
to be uh
you know very strategic in how we do
that we started off with prevention
programs and koch is going to outline
the prevention programs that that we did
in building up our capacity to to do
prevention then we went to
community-based programs and we built up
that capacity next was crisis-based
programs which you saw a statewide
mobile crisis
mobile crisis rapid response
and then you come to the most expensive
in the smallest part of our system which
is your inpatient capacity once we've
built out
the other three tiers
what is left is inpatient so this past
year and actually over the last two
years
what you will see is is in an investment
in the inpatient capacity i truly
believe
that people should be able to receive
care in their communities i don't
believe that people should need to
travel to one hospital in this state
have no choice on where they receive
their care i believe that everybody
should have a choice so
we started with hampstead
making sure that we
invested in children's behavioral health
services in
inpatient care you will see an expansion
of prtf which is psychiatric residential
treatment facility for kids once we own
that building
and it really solidifies our investment
for children
for
the long term
we started building the forensic
hospital so the plans are done we expect
to break ground next year it's 24 beds
much less than what what we asked for
but
the building is being built that if we
need to add on in the future we can
what that will do is take 24 civilly
committed patients out of spu at the
state prison and bring them into a
clinical environment at new hampshire
hospital we expect that to be done in
about two years
two additional investments that we're
making
one which is very well known is the hca
investment
we're asking for 15 million dollars to
invest in a new psychiatric consolidated
psychiatric hospital in epping new
hampshire
as a capital defragment
for a commitment period of 10 years
what this 15 million buys us is about 40
new inpatient beds and some leverage
that we prioritize new hampshire
residents that we
we can ask for a certain percentage of
medicaid
that we ask for
relationships with the community mental
health centers
so that's a really important investment
that has uh
we we brought that initially forward
almost two months ago now it is tied up
in the in the approval process we're
hoping to get that move forward in the
coming weeks
there will be a second
project that i bring forward with an
additional 15 million dollar investment
to build a similar size hospital in the
southern part of the state although not
near wrapping
both hospitals will have specialty
programs for adolescents for gerry
psychiatry eating disorders
you know
diagnostic assessments and a variety of
other specialties
when we have when our system our mental
health system specifically our hospital
capacity
runs at a hundred percent occupancy at a
hundred percent of the time
it doesn't serve the patient well
if you can just imagine if every
hospital was at a hundred percent
capacity you're just putting people in
beds without
thought of does
are they receiving the the same type of
care so you may have someone that is
clinically depressed
rooming with someone that is manic
not exactly a good pairing and not very
therapeutic for that person either
so as we build out capacity it gives us
the ability to start specializing in
programs
like many states if it right now if you
want specialized care for uh for ocd
you would go to mclean because we don't
have an ocd clinic here in new hampshire
if you wanted specialized programming
for a multitude of mental health
disorders
you would go out of this state because
we do not have that capacity here as we
build capacity the goal
is to build out our specialty care so
new hampshire citizens can get their
care in their communities and in our
state
probably five years ago i was asked to
fix this the mental health system i was
asked by both parties by the house by
the senate by the governor
by the executive council
um
i
you're going to hear from kacha and and
you've seen what we've done thus far to
try to fix these issues
this is what i believe is going to fix
it's been very
strategic on
what we built out first but it is now
time to build out the inpatient setting
so with that i am going to hand it over
to kacha one question if i may the last
of these series of facilities
uh do i remember correctly that this is
a joint venture with a hospital
the i i haven't been able to bring the
name forward i do expect to be able to
bring it forward in the next three or
four weeks it is a current hospital in
the state of new hampshire yes
i won't bring it forward either
thank you
any other questions yes representative
edwards this is just a small detail on
that i've been tracking um you mentioned
specifically epping as the site location
for the 40 beds
do you know
how mature that decision is has it been
finalized has epping
signed off on all the permits and
everything because i i understand epping
is devoid of the sewer and water
over in the area that is needed and and
that that it's still in the air so could
you give me an update on
leadership from portsmouth hospital
which is an hca hospital has met with
the town of epping
they do have a personal land picked out
when we started these discussions
probably
in the fall
with the hope to bringing it forward in
january their intent was to break ground
this spring
so
with the delay in having the having this
kind of caught up in the approval
process i'm not sure if they're still
going to be able to break ground in the
spring it depends on how quickly we can
move forward because what's caught up
right now or what's being delayed is the
accept and expend of federal funds we
haven't even got to the contracting
process yet
because
i need to accept it i need i need
approval to accept the federal funds
before i can hit the negotiation table
um so that that's going to take several
months to do um my understanding is that
they have had conversations with the
town of epping to you know the town of
epping wants to make sure that you know
the tax revenue is still going to be
there and and um i i don't believe
there's any issues that has been brought
forward around building it on the site
they had planned
thank you commissioner i do have a
follow-up
can you stay for one more yeah i'm gonna
stay until kochi is done okay so the
follow-up on that would just be um
i know that the joint fiscal committee
uh approved the uh acceptance and
expenditure when you say you're still
waiting something what what what are you
waiting on did the executive council not
act or what
the executive councilor council have not
has we have not had sufficient votes at
the executive council so we've had to
remove it from the agenda
for four meetings now or not put it on
the agenda for four meetings so i have a
non-meeting with the executive council
next week hoping to be able to answer
their questions so we can put it on the
following meeting and get the votes to
get it passed thank you
thank you commissioner
and welcome mr
fox
so good morning uh
mr chair and members of the committee
i'm katya foxx i'm the director of the
division for
behavioral health for the department i'm
going to walk you through the slide deck
but i'm not going to read it word for
word
because
there are many many details as we get
further into the
into the presentation i do want to
apologize right up front that we did not
include page numbers so
perhaps we'll take questions as we
go along and rather than having to flip
back and forth as we go so i'll pause
after
when we start getting into those details
i also do want to recognize that um
julianne carbon and rebecca ross will be
following me and they will have some
more specific details which were a
request that was made i believe it
originated with senator rosenwald last
year and have been carried over for a
period of time so we will be addressing
those um
they will be addressing those as we go
along so i'll note those
so what we wanted to do this morning is
to provide to you
a an update on where we're at so we
often
for an example they're going to provide
information about specific programs but
we want to be able to provide a bigger
picture of where we're at and our
strategy and how each of these
components that you hear about
either through the news or through
legislation or through particular
updates how they all fit together
so
one commitment that was made as part of
the 10-year plan is that we would not
have it just be a plan that sits on the
shelf that it's a living breathing
document and that we will continue to
update it and to continue to get
as much information and be
as relevant as possible given the times
when we said say 10 years it does
in some ways it doesn't seem like it's
very long
and that the
plan that was at put forth will be
relevant 10 years later but as we know
from our experience over the last couple
years things change
so
some of the first couple of pages have
to do with some of the statistics
they're always a good reminder to have
before us so that we know
the people that we're serving and how
many of our community members are
impacted
by
the
behavioral health challenges
so
and we have all the sources cited so if
you have questions about that we can
provide those
so we talk about the adult population
one in four
we talk about children with depression
yet aren't receiving treatment
we talk about
children
and youth involved with the child
welfare system
and what we're finding with
that particular population and how many
of them
have these mental health disorders and
challenges
and what led them there um so
you know that's a lot of the work that
our partner at the division
for
children youth and families joe ripsom
and i work on together
yes representative edwards
thank you and thank you miss fox on the
page where it says 47 percent of new
hampshire children with depression are
not receiving treatment
what
what is a reasonable attainable goal for
what that percentage ought to be
and do you have statistics pre-pandemic
2017-18 that would indicate you know
what the pandemic has done to set us
back
so i will take your last question first
and say that we can provide that to you
and give that comparison
um of course my response is going to be
a hundred percent um are receiving
treatment but to be realistic we would
want to see this number
cut in half
thank you because we we need to budget
for reasonable
goals and not for perfection you mean
for idealistic like um i just stated i'm
glad you're an idealist though
i'm a cynic sorry
all right um
this slide that shows the adverse
impacts we have included this this is
something that samsa
has developed and it really shows the
stages that
happen when there has been um a
an event
what we have found is that when we first
started seeing this slide in 2020
that uh it it assumed that there was a
disaster and that there was a hurricane
that there was a tornado that there was
a flood um or something to that effect
what we didn't anticipate when this
first uh was
put forth in those publications was that
we would have a duration of the time
period that we've had with the pandemic
and so
you could go along this line and see
where we're at and say okay we're right
here
and then we could be thrown right back
and we saw that with the
variants and the waves that we've
experienced
so um
optimistic again reconstruction that's
where we are and that's what we're
working with
as we as we go through this
10-year plan and the efforts that we're
taking
with our behavioral health systems
the drivers of transformation
there have been many
they evolve and so of course there's the
recognition we had the recognition
well before the pandemic with the
creation of the
of the 10-year plan
and the children's system of care the
statute that addresses children's needs
we've had a window of opportunity we
have medicaid everyone thinks of
medicaid is just paying the doctor's
bills and covering routine services
medicaid has evolved so that it's become
a driver of change it's a tool that
we're able to use and able to create
different types of approaches that are
more
appropriate for communities and less a
medical model so that really has evolved
and changed and we've been able to use
that flexibility and able to stand up
some more systems as a result of that in
doing things differently
community-based investments we'll talk a
lot about those and the commissioner
just addressed the institutional care
vision and values i'll let you read that
of course number one it's
needs to be centered and driven by the
individuals and their families
and again i i'm going to leave it so
that you can read this at a later time
and go into
more of the details the the next slide
the next page which has the inverted
triangle
is looking at the different levels that
we are facing and how we go from lower
acute acuity to higher acuity
and when i look at this at first i was
like okay shouldn't prevention and early
intervention be at the foundation and be
at the bottom but if you really look at
this as a funnel
we look at population health in the top
um with prevention and early
intervention and then we see and that's
where we serve we and we
need to invest even more
in serving the greatest population
across the state and then we start
getting down into the different levels
based on the different levels of needs
so
community-based services we're going to
talk a lot about that again julianne and
rebecca will be highlighting a couple of
areas
we have crisis response that is again
they'll be talking about new hampshire
rapid response the mobile crisis
and that's really something that we
spent a considerable amount of time a
lot of investment a lot of work with our
community partners to stand up a system
that can be
responsive to individuals before they
hit the highest level and and have the
highest need which is that acute and
specialty care so this means in real
words emergency room diversion
why would somebody need to go to an
emergency room if they could be served
in their home or in their community and
we want to
be able to have that on the front lines
and um have people served where
frankly it makes more sense
so
i'll pause representative edwards
so i i think you you probably hit the
slide that says prevention and early
intervention the the subtitle under that
refers to addressing the social
determinants of behavioral health
which just makes me wonder to what
extent are the social determinants of
behavioral health distinct from
social determinants of health
what what new things are being brought
into this when you say that
they really are the same
there are so many drivers um one one
area that does come to mind um is
for behavioral health is the adverse
childhood experiences
and how those impact and that's a
behavioral
health need that needs to be addressed
early
so that we have that intervention so it
doesn't manifest itself
in a more
complex way moving forward thank you
all right um so again this goes into
details here for each one of those
components so prevention and early
intervention one thing that became very
clear uh through the 10-year plan was
that we were not doing enough to
specifically call out and address
suicide prevention
and so there have been a lot of efforts
around that for the very first time the
legislature had funded
actually put funding behind
this effort
and we were able to in the department
hire a suicide prevention
coordinator and that coordinator works
very closely with a suicide prevention
council in carrying out these efforts
there have been trainings in schools
and then again the rapid response which
you'll see repeated throughout
we've had the first episode psychosis
again an early intervention if you have
someone who experiences a crisis very
early on getting those regional teams in
and having them address those needs to
prevent
further
complex needs down the line
and we always have training and
consultation which seems
like a luxury but it's not a luxury it's
an investment that we need to make so
that we have
as much
evidence-based practice going on so that
we can achieve the outcomes that we need
family supports this has been really
critical this fast forward program which
is families and systems together that is
a program that serves over 400 families
and continues to grow it was a very
small program when we first started and
it has been so successful in helping
families
address the needs of their children
that it again it's more investment and
more time but it's
the payoff is great
representative edwards
so it sounds like we've got 400 families
receiving intensive family supports i'm
just because we've talked about equity
earlier in the slide deck i'm just
curious
if you know anything about the
demographics of those 400 and if those
demographics
map the standard new hampshire profile
and if not how what are the distinctions
i do not have that oh thank you um i do
not have that information here it's
something that we can provide we do have
a breakdown of demographics on this
uh thank you looking forward to it
all right again um i find myself before
this committee the only times that i've
appeared i'm always looking at my watch
saying wow
i need to speed up and i and i don't do
that the person who uh
plans my schedule for me is
very thorough in the amount of work
given to us so we like to move along
quickly
okay great so again i'll be available
for follow-up questions at any point in
time and would be happy to entertain
those and come back at a different time
community-based services
substance use disorders we haven't
talked a lot about the services that we
have there
this is the
doorway program
it's recovery supports we have over a
dozen
recovery community organizations across
the state
we have respite services and we have
overdose prevention
first and foremost the distribution of
naloxone throughout our communities
housing
julianne and rebecca will be talking
more about housing so i think i'll
skip through that
peer support with our workforce
shortages that persist
we know that the investment in in the
peer network and the workforce is really
important going forward and we're taking
many opportunities to be able to invest
in peer support
flipping over to acute
the commissioner has addressed
the drfs which
in
in case it's not obvious the hospitals
that we're talking about and the new
beds that we're talking about will be
designated receiving facilities
we have a waiver um and i know henry
lipman is here as medicaid director if
you want more information about what the
waiver does be happy to talk about that
but that's another mechanism whereby
which we're able to obtain federal
matching funds from medicaid to help us
pay for those
those beds
the prtf the commissioner did
address and that is part of the
hampstead plan to be able to have that
level of care which is in it's in
between the community-based beds and the
acute setting it's really the highest
need before
a child would need to go into
an acute psychiatric
hospital
before we move on under hampstead
hospital operation and expansion
now by expansion i'm going to assume
that simply means
there's presently about 35 residents in
a facility that can hold over 100 and
we're hoping to move it up to the
maximum it does not mean bricks and
mortar expansion just to be clear thank
you
yes that is correct good got it
i'll be asked on this one
absolutely there's no intent there are
111 beds that are currently licensed and
there's a lot of groom room to grow and
expand within those licensed beds
again the forensic hospital has been
addressed
supportive transitions critical time
intervention is a new program for the
state of new hampshire it is something
that was supported by the legislature
and the funding of this program which is
to have an individual who works with
someone who is exiting
in transitioning from new hampshire
hospital or a drf and get into the
community and be successful
so this is about the skills that are
needed to maintain someone's
health
including behavioral health and that
includes making sure that they have all
the supports and we talked about the
social determinants that they have all
of those supports
and checking in on them so it's one
person who follows someone
throughout a period of nine months and
that program is
being run by our community mental health
centers we have four centers that have
it now and it will expand july 1st to
all centers
again more training
we have the
next slide with the enabling
infrastructure
and what that looks like of course
that's all about funding and mechanisms
to be successful in the
carrying out of all these programs
and then we just have the appendix which
really talks about again referring back
to
the
facility level of care that the
commissioner has already addressed
and with that i'd be happy to answer
more questions or step aside
senator
thank you mr chairman thanks katja i
have three questions if i could um
i know that as of
um january this year
all of the community mental health
centers were
tasked with opening up crisis
intervention teams but also
opening crisis beds how many beds are
currently online and is it all of them
so um i'm going to defer to jillian
carbon the director of the bureau of
mental health services who will be
addressing that in the next presentation
great and um i think you said that
the hampstead
i mean sorry the hca expansion and the
one
who has not yet been named
will be
drf beds but in the past i think the
department has said they would be dually
licensed
has that changed no they will be both
they will be uh duly both voluntary
involuntary um obviously like children's
beds
we don't typically have drf beds in
children's services because
kids can be admitted by their their
guardian voluntary by guardian so for
adult population they will be both
voluntary and involuntary thank you and
finally
in terms of medicaid rate increases does
the department think our medicaid rates
are now high enough
and if not is the department planning to
bring forward
rate increases in the next budget
that's something i'm going to have to
defer to henry on henry is our medicaid
expert the drf rate specifically we
doubled about two years ago
so i assume that we are talking about
community-based care
we just did an increase for transitional
housing services with the
community-based programs
that took
effect last july i believe
and um
because there is a requirement for them
to each build out six additional beds
for transitional housing so we did
increase their rates uh back in july
the community
based other rates like i said henry
henry could address that for you thank
you
and if i could just add on that um
that we look at that often there are
many of those rates that now are um
more they're they're adequate um
and we always have some lines of service
that are out of black um so we always
look at those as well but we have some
other payment mechanisms i'd be happy to
talk to you about and i'm sure henry
would as well
that are directed payments to incent
certain
programs and activities by the
i'm more familiar with the
transportation
10-year plan which always struck me as
structured enough so you're not
wandering around aimlessly yet fluid
enough so that certain things can be
adjusted as needed this strikes me as
similar to that is that your intent
that was a softball
absolutely that's exactly what we're
trying to get at at the beginning of the
presentation that it does need to be
flexible
i think that 10 years is a long time and
in healthcare
best practices evolve over that 10-year
period so as much as we lay out our
strategy when something new like cti is
not in the 10-year mental health plan
but it is a an exceptional program that
was brought to us new york state has
done it
and it does address the overall concept
in the 10-year mental health plan which
is transitions of care but it's not
specifically called out so it provides
us a strategy but we need that
flexibility within that strategy to to
take advantage of new
new programs and new ideas and mental
health i'm doing the same with my board
of directors so i understand it thank
you so much
representative mckay
thank you mr chairman for letting me sit
in today
the ketchup
as you know i have a
significant interest in this
10-year plan and the 10-year plan that
came before this
what one of my goals is to
bring back the mental health caucus
that representative snow and myself and
several others
including our chairman want to
participate in that program but my goal
is that
when mental health
legislation comes in front of us
that we use this 10 year plan
as the guide
and we have had one legislation
one piece of legislation
this year that was rather sensitive
that this plan helped us very much to
deal with that legislation around peer
support
so
this is not a warning that
that we're bringing that caucus back but
that
we certainly seek your
participation and the team participation
and we very much appreciate
what the commissioner has done
uh because i remember the days over in
the county so that
we are pleased with that
as well so thank you very much for
letting me sit here
representative nelson
yes thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
as a novice involved in all of this have
we always had this
these problems percentage wise as in you
know going back 10 15 years ago or is a
lot of the inc is an increase and if
there is an increase any sense of why
so i think um that i am not i this is
just me and not any statistic i'm going
to use um off the top of my head but
that we have always had this problem um
this problem uh has been something that
has not been addressed because we didn't
talk about it
we never talked about mental health we
never do you know came out and said i
have a problem
i need help i'm struggling and now that
we have had the support of the
legislature and
of the governor and the policy makers to
be able to talk about it and normalize
it
i think that's why we are seeing some of
those increases but i also think that
there are factors that come in
um such as the pandemic that create
additional uh need
and i'll i'll just add to that that
you know back in the
i would say the 80s and the 90s we
probably had one of the most evolved
mental health systems in our country
we
de-institutionalized what was about 3
000 patients at new hampshire hospital
all of those buildings on that campus
had patients in them at one time
and i think what you've seen between the
year of 2000 and year 2011 2012 is this
very small erosion of our system over
time
with the kind of the breaking point
coming in 2011 when they closed the
annafell brook children's hospital and
they moved the kids into new hampshire
hospital that removed 44 beds from
the pool of adult beds that's when the
waitlist started but in addition to that
change we saw small community-based
programs close and maybe it was only 10
beds or 12 beds but when you have one of
those programs close every single year
before long your infrastructure suffers
so we saw this very slow erosion of our
system
that led up to kind of the crisis point
of where we're at now so now we are
rebuilding the system that we once had
and it's going to take several years to
do that
commissioner i was living in
massachusetts at the time when an
extensive series of mental health
hospitals were being closed all over the
state with a view to establish
community-based and as i recollect the
big enemy against
okay now that you've closed these what
are you going to open was nimby
was that the case in new hampshire or
would you point to other factors as well
um i think that that that there is
always um some part of nimby that that
enters into mental health there are you
know we we address the stigma issue um
there's a lot of work to be done around
stigma um stigma in our communities uh
you know there is not a lot of people
that will live in an apartment building
and have someone that maybe
you know is having hallucinations or
delusions next door and they're talking
to themselves there's not a lot of
people that embrace those people right
or our homeless person on the sidewalk
that that you know to the rest of us
seems like they're acting different
so there is a lot of stigma that goes
there that we need to as a society to
move past and and really kind of embrace
that vulnerable part of our population
i think the people that need inpatient
care need inpatient care and
you know i think that is uh
something that we're realizing right now
it doesn't matter
how many community-based programs when
someone is in crisis and needs that
inpatient bed there's not another
program that's going to replace an
inpatient bed we everything that
everything that can
defer them from the hospital we're doing
the the crisis the mobile crisis all of
those things but when someone really
gets there we need the inpatient bed
thank you
one more and then we'll move on to our
next report representative edwards okay
i'll just share these observations about
this plan and you can you don't have to
respond you could just figure out what
you want to do with these comments
um
on enabling infrastructure
it seems to me like you want to have a
fourth line in here for information
technology i know we're doing so much in
the it space and i gotta assume that
some amount of it
is necessary to be done in order to help
become part of your enabling
infrastructure the other thing that when
i look at
a
set of lines like this
like in the future step area if if you
considered
doing a red green yellow kind of a
status thing so it's easier to draw our
attention to what's going well and what
you know the red ones might be the ones
that we need to do something about which
which opens up the third observation
which is uh i don't know if you'd want
to do this in here but uh
maybe you could consider a page on
legislative support priorities
so that you know we know you guys are
working but we don't know
from this i can't tell
what the legislature needs to be doing
to
to work with you in coming years so
no need to respond just thoughts
i will respond however just to say those
are very good tips for upcoming
legislative process that we're going to
be facing very very soon
and thank you miss fox and thank you
commissioner appreciate
now we're trying to catch up we had
three items
that we didn't get to in january and the
snowstorm ran us out in february but we
also have a leftover from september 24th
2021 designated receiving facilities and
transitional housing beds and mobile
crises teams
update rebecca ross julianne carbon
and friends
i see other people moving around too oh
that's okay
okay good morning
i'm julianne carbon i'm the director for
the bureau of mental health services
i'm joined by
morning for the record rebecca ross
director of the bureau for children's
behavioral health
and i think we can we can start by
addressing senator rosenwald's question
regarding the crisis housing and we do
have a handout and i think in future
iterations given the question we'll add
a little bit more detail about the
crisis response services um but it's a
handout that looks like this with the
kind of circles on the side
and um so in addition to the crisis
mobile crisis apartments that we have we
also have the step up step down
apartments run by our peer support
agencies but i think the question you
had was really around the additional 60
beds that we recently um contracted for
show us what that looks like again it
should be this one with the well i'm
running out of paper and i don't have
one of those
okay it might be underneath these one
these colorful ones
got it
we do have an eye doctor in the room if
needed representative
don't ask me what color
okay
we're good okay fantastic
um and so i mean this creates a summary
but essentially what we have seen is
that the housing market is very tight
and so that has created some barriers
for our agencies to move forward with
purchasing of properties
as well as even getting supplies in so
getting refrigerators beds things to
actually furnish the apartments with has
been
causing delays and with our transitional
housing programs it's been some delays
with both
furnishing the apartments and staffing
and so
excuse me
nine of the ten centers have been
contracted to
expand their six bed programs and are
all actively working on
purchasing properties and getting them
set up none are open today accepting new
clients but they're all in process and
that's something that our team is
working very closely with the centers on
monitoring and supporting that expansion
so we can move on to the exciting stuff
of rapid response
thanks julianne we're just going to give
a quick update i know this was the
update we were supposed to give a couple
months ago um
as you're aware rapid response launched
on
january 1 and we have some of that
january data overall we would call it a
success it is up and operating
there have been deployments in every
state what we're going to do is put
together some high-level data that we're
going to transition into a regular
monthly report
this is preliminary data it's the first
month we're still working hard to verify
that data and combine it with other data
sources so this will grow and expand
over time but this is the initial
snapshot of what we've seen
and as a reminder mobile crisis allows
individuals in the community to call
text or chat through a centralized
access point
about 75 percent of those encounters are
resolved over the phone through that
access point and about a quarter of them
result in deployments so in january
there were a little over 1500 contacts
with unique individuals so
that was
you know within the range of what we
expected there's still additional
outreach and education with the
community as we're going forward we
anticipate that would grow um but 1500
contacts in the first 30 days is
certainly
demonstrating that there is engagement
statewide
we have confirmed that there have been
deployments in all parts of the state
and all regions as well so we know it is
it is operating across the board
i'm happy to take questions at any time
if you want to jump in
yeah um i know what the word
transitional means but could you give a
little bit of narrative
as to
who is transitioning from what to where
okay so for mobile crisis
it's we are calling it the
new hampshire rapid response access
point and that is a crisis response that
anyone can call in on behalf of
themselves or on behalf of
another individual there will be
triage and
coordination on the phone and if
the individual services can or needs can
be met through services on the phone
then they can arrange follow-up care or
come up with another plan for that
individual if the individual believes
that they need to see someone in person
we have a team that can go out statewide
and see them
we're partnering with our community
mental health centers so the access
point would transition to deploy a
community mental health center they're
all in the process of standing up their
teams staffing is certainly a challenge
for all of them and particularly in
certain regions of the state but they
all have functioning teams there's also
the capacity to
be deployed to another region so if one
region is fully deployed or unavailable
the access point will then go to the
next available closest region and deploy
so they're coordinating the services
statewide for the deployment teams that
are operating out of our community
mental health centers thank you
we saw about 80
of the individuals served were adults
and
um a little under 20 were
youth so under 18
and that was
290 youth under 18 that's a population
that was never served by the three prior
mobile crisis teams so we are definitely
seeing that that engagement is getting
out there that did also cover all of
the regions so
um we'll work on increasing that
utilization to avoid hospitalization and
avoid emergency departments but
that reflects that it is in fact up and
running across the board
there were in 30 days there were over
400 mobile deployments that means the
team's going out
um
and again those were statewide and 120
of those were for youth so for about a
third of the youth that called in or a
little more than a third
the team went out and engaged with the
youth so
we will work on the data we'll work on
adding trending data and a little bit
deeper dive but overall for that
snapshot for the first month for
something brand new statewide
we have had a great experience with our
contractor and their collaboration with
our community mental health centers to
to operationalize across the state
any questions
representative edwards
just a
coordination point with you as much as
anyone mr chair
one of the future topics i had requested
and i wouldn't ask for any of it today
but i'd like to
at some point get a summary of all the
mobile mental health team fans i i just
want to know i think we're supposed to
end up with five of them
i'd be curious to to go into the detail
on how well we're doing on stacking
those things up so
is that's in your purview right you're
tracking the mobile response teams
okay teams but were you asking
specifically about vehicles
the whole pro
it's like a bed
you you you have to have the staff you
have to have everything around it so
when i when i think about these five
mobile response vans i think of all the
capability that needs to be associated
with it to make it productive and so i'd
like
in a future hhs if we oversight
do a deep dive on where we are with uh
standing up those vans and how
productive they each are being not in
the aggregate
okay i think julianne is going to give
we can talk offline i'm afraid i'm just
burning too much time we will we do have
some additional information about teams
for you today
um the other visual that looks like this
that's color coded gives again a visual
snapshot of where we're at with staffing
up our teams
by region and so i think tying some of
the data to that is what we will look at
in future months but this gives you
again just an overview of the of the
staffing and as you can see third shift
is where we have the most significant
amount of staffing challenges and so as
we mentioned last time we are looking at
this as a statewide response system so
if someone calls texts or chats and
needs a mobile response
and we don't have one available um you
know we will be trying to deploy support
via telehealth if um and using any
region that has a clinician available
and then the last resort would be
referring someone to
an emergency department but we have
other options like next day appointments
and things like that
thank you for your report
thank you thank you
next on our agenda is a follow-up to
house bill 1290
and representative rogers who is the
sponsor of it is here with us
today
this
is a bill that came to my health and
human services and elderly affairs
committee
and we thought that the best vehicle to
establish a task force was not
through
um the descriptors the lines in the bill
but in something that would better come
under
this oversight committee
that was our
unanimous conclusion
i had asked representative soloway to
take and run with it he was most
articulate in the committee when we
looked at this and i asked him to
develop something and present it to us
today so representative soloway
uh thank you very much mr chairman uh
i'm delighted to have representative
rogers here with us uh today
um
the bill that she drafted that brought
that came before health and human
services was articulate it had a
remarkably good blueprint for how a task
force might proceed
i had one major objection
to that bill and that was it called for
a final report due november of 2024
it was my own sense and the sense of the
committee that uh such a report on an
emerging technology for biomarker
testing
for
precision medicine
didn't
wouldn't stand a two-year delay in the
final report that we needed to be
much more forward-looking dare i say
much more aggressive and agile in
putting together a report and therefore
i moved interim study on that bill with
direction to the chairman of health and
human services oversight of course
chairman pearson
that it be remanded to this oversight
committee for much more immediate action
i would point out that representative
rogers
has brought
to us a wonderful opportunity it's a
two-fold opportunity one of them
obviously is to deal with the issue at
hand
let's take a look at the technology for
precision medicine and let's see what we
can do to enhance that technology here
in new hampshire but at the same time
she instructs us that
the process of developing legislation is
the attempt to sharpen what is basically
a blunt tool we in the legislature work
with a if you will blunt tool and the
questions are
is it our role in the legislature to
create legislation to facilitate such
technologies i.e to implement them as a
state activity
is it
perhaps our role to encourage
the development of such technologies
perhaps to incentivize them government
does this routinely with things like tax
incentives
is it our role to publicize to
emerge as
loud speakers on the bully pulpit to get
our colleagues in the professional
organizations
to get the word out to practitioners and
to the public that these technologies
exist
and can be and should be utilized
and
finally
is it our role to provide oversight to
regulate
these technologies perhaps through the
oversight committee with that we sit
with today or perhaps to create a role
for dhhs in regulating these activities
so in this regard
i would like to request of the chair
that
he appoint
a task force from this committee to
begin work immediately
on this
hopefully with a final report due
within a matter of months and not years
i would hope that this can be done in
three or four months time with intensive
activity
i would add parenthetically just for my
own purposes that for those of you who
are interested the cost of this emerging
technology right now is quite
extraordinary
representative rogers has a gofundme
site
for those of you who are interested
please access that gofundme site and
decide if you wish to participate there
as well but mr chairman i would
respectfully request that
you consider the appointment of a task
force to deal with the issues of
biomarkers precision medicine genetic
testing and all the technologies that
are associated
thank you representative might i uh try
to massage that a little bit and suggest
a task force
of just a few of us to work
with you as really the prime mover on
this
then to delineate what a future task
force subgroup of this committee would
be
with whom we would like to
attract to be part of our work from even
around the country in other words a step
before the step
and i should think that if there were
three or four of us
we could bat this off in an afternoon
and come up with a plan of what a
subgroup like we did with representative
rice
might look like
look at the kinds of people that you've
already
initially bounced thoughts off and go
from there
how would that sound
as always mr chairman you have a
wonderful sense of organization and i'm
all for it and we'll be glad to work on
that
in that case um
[Music]
do we have a couple of other people
who would like to spend that afternoon
to flesh out
what the later
bigger
and i hope ongoing
subcommittee of this group would be like
i would like to say yes i just need to
give you a heads up i'm i'm not in the
state the first two weeks of april
okay
um
do i see nodding
i would like to participate in this
meeting as well we have soloway edwards
marsh pearson say one or two others as i
say i really see this as an afternoon's
work
to
come back with a two or three page paper
to us as to what this subcommittee then
going forward would look like anybody
want to play
representative mckay
you used to chair this group didn't you
well you get alumni alumnus status on
this so absolutely
all right um
mr chairman may i respectfully request
that we ask uh councillor williams to
sit with us as ex officio
sure you may request that
would you do that
thank you
he didn't say i but he stood good thank
you
anything further on this
good representative soloway if you could
figure out how to pull us all together
at a time when we can all be there uh do
it at your place you provide drinks and
snacks
thank you
next on our agenda senate bill
118 of 2019 child fatality review
committee annual report patricia tilley
director of the division of public
health services dhhs
good morning chair good morning
committee thank you for having us here
today um
as many of you know dr sai chiralla has
transitioned to a wonderful new position
to us in a state south of us right now
so you have i know it's sad so you get
the jv team today which is me giving
this report so thank you all in the
interest of time i'm going to shorten it
up but i'm always happy to entertain
questions as we move along
for more than 20 years the work and the
data of the child fatality review
committee has helped policies and
practices that we now take for granted
including policies about car seats for
kids how we train child care providers
and health care providers to put infants
to sleep and seat belt laws for children
and adolescents and and by the way you
all have a copy of the report right here
in front of you there's also extras over
over on the side
the hallmark of this child fatality
review committee is its data-driven
approach and multi-disciplinary
membership we have folks from public
health behavioral health child
protection the chief medical examiner
judicial representatives safety
community partners this group selects
cases from the previous year to review
to guide recommendations for system
changes to improve services and supports
for infants children and young and youth
the good news of this 2021 report is
that new hampshire's child mortality
rate continues to be well below the
national average the report provides
detailed information about state level
trends
that we garner from the death
certificate data
among children and and youth ages
0 to 21 all of whom are residents of the
state of new hampshire the data spans
from 2016 to 2020.
deaths due to
natural causes the underlying underlying
medical condition comprised about 56
percent of the total deaths in 2020 for
children birth through age 21 and about
43 percent of those deaths were from
injuries
the highest number of deaths occur among
our infants those less than one year old
that's about 35 percent of the total and
87 of those deaths among infants or from
natural causes often causes um from
perinatal conditions
the next highest death rate was among
those between 19 and 21. so again you
see the very youngest among excess and
then the older age group at the end of
the spectrum and most of those deaths
among the 19 to 21 year olds were not
from natural causes but from injuries
both intentional and unintentional
suicide is the leading cause of
intentional injury in children ages 1 to
21 and the incidence of suicide deaths
is among the is the highest among youth
19 to 21 years old
a little outside of the scope of the
child fatality review committee but i
think it's still important to mention is
that self-harm and suicide ideation
talking about it thinking about it
writing about it
among youth increased during the
pandemic
but we are thankful that overall the
completed suicide rates um do not to
have it do not appear to have increased
in fact the numbers may have even
decreased a little bit but given that
fortunately we have so few of them in
the state the sensitivity of whether
that's significant is still out there so
um the good news is is that we did not
see a spike in youth suicide over the
pandemic however we have troubling
indicators and as my colleague katya and
her entire team will note we have still
have significant need for the behavioral
health system as we saw increases in
both suicide ideation and self-harm so
but back to this group
during 2012
when you look at unintentional injury
among children and youth ages 1 to 21
you'll see that poisoning deaths due to
opioids again overdose deaths or related
to opioids motor vehicles
are accidents and land transport
accidents like atvs
um and blunt force trauma and drowning
top out the leading causes of
unintentional injury deaths so again
overdose deaths that's about 39 percent
of those motor vehicle accidents about
and other land transport atvs
snowmobiles 14
during 2021 the committee held six
review meetings reviewed eight cases
which included four drug related
fatalities and four motor vehicle
accidents
after reviewing the cases the committee
proposed around 10 recommendations that
are listed in the report you can see
those along with the responsible party
or agency to follow up and implement
those recommendations the
recommendations reflect
the public health impact in improving
the lives of children and the impact of
improving the efficacy and efficiency of
the agencies identified under those
recommendations some of the highlights
include guidance for parents and young
drivers about winter driving and
maintenance
increased use of driving simulators for
young drivers to renew and refresh
campaigns about and public education
focused on adolescent for as lessons
around seat belt use impaired driving
what to do when you're a passenger in
the car and you're uncomfortable with
who's driving and in their state to be
driving tools for adolescents to be able
to navigate those really tricky
situations that i think all of us can
recall from back in our younger days
there are also recommendations for
systems and policy change including
improving the completeness of records
around child fatalities from crashes
including identifying
requirements for crash reconstruction
when youth fatalities are involved
other recommendations around exploring
the pros and cons of additional
restrictions related to graduated
driver's licenses for young adults
some of the recommendations also focus
on upstream approaches to reduce and
prevent adverse childhood experiences
you just heard katya fox talk about the
importance of addressing those adverse
childhood experiences or aces early in a
family's lives so that we can prevent
some of the worst outcomes of behavioral
health problems
we know that increased
that aces in early childhood may lead to
increased risk-taking behaviors and
increase the chance for children and
youth to again experience substance use
and other behavioral health conditions
recommendations in the report include
improving referral systems for home
visiting programs and other wraparound
services broad training about the impact
of aces for education for our partners
in the schools for child care providers
and improving communication between
schools health care providers and
behavioral health providers
in the report you can also take a look
at updates on recommendations from the
previous year and where we've made
progress
additionally two subcommittees of the
child fatality review committee were
approved this year one on sudden death
and the young and one on sudden
unexpected infant death some of you may
remember that as sids
the in 2021 the sudden unexpected infant
death program made some significant
progress with safe sleep
work groups developing campaigns for
community awareness
sued case reviews identified targeted
populations where to focus education
efforts such as health care providers
parents and caregivers who co-sleep with
their infants one strategy that the
state the safe sleep work group
developed was to hold four town hall
style zoom meetings in twenty twenty
twenty that's a lot of twos
2022 to really start bringing all of
those stakeholders and those community
members together to talk about safe
sleep practices so i'm going to somewhat
there given the time that we have
together but i'm happy to take questions
i want to make sure that we have time on
the agenda available for all the other
important updates one question from the
chair i see most of the responsible
parties are
aspects of dhhs or doe
is there anything in there that i may
have missed where
you would want to come to a few of us as
legislators to craft something as a
lsr over the summer
thank you very much for that question
and that's a great idea i think the
group right now doesn't have a
particular policy in mind a piece of
legislation that they think will make a
difference but we'll certainly share
that with the group as they come
together to do that work
thank you any other questions
representative edwards uh this is a
definitional one on page eight you talk
about certain conditions originating in
the perinatal period
and my understanding is the word
perinatal is is uh
not consistently defined sometimes it's
seven days after birth sometimes it's 28
days
uh do you how how do you define or how
does the department in this report
define the perinatal period
thanks for that question um since this
comes straight from the
death certificate information i i will
i'll have to go back and get the exact
definition for you but you're correct it
usually has some expansive number after
uh after birth so i'll follow up with
you
follow up and then you've got three
great contact lists of who the members
are yes it would be nice if you could
consider including um a point of contact
method if they are okay with email or
phone calls just in case somebody wanted
to reach out i will let them know thank
you all right thanks
representative marsh uh yes thank you
this is a follow-up to representative
pearson's question has the funding for
genetic testing for sewage cases been
adequately addressed or do we need
further legislation for that
for genetic testing um i i don't know
that i can answer that fully right now
i'm happy to have an offline
conversation there's certainly no
funding through the department to do
that it would be a larger you know
obviously a much broader conversation um
among insurance carriers
uh thank you my understanding was it was
with the chief medical examiner's office
but we can continue
thank you miss tilly it's always good to
have you with us thank you
now we move on to rsa 128 11 house bill
79 laws of 2021
new hampshire health officers
association annual report
mr wayne whitford
and mr matthew
cahilaine
and
someone else
good morning chairman pearson my name is
sophia johnson
and i am a health officer specialist at
the department of health and human
services
you may begin when ready thank you good
morning chairman pearson members of the
committee my name is wayne whitford i'm
president of the new hampshire health
office association i'm here at the
invitation of the committee to discuss
the state readiness report
and the ability of townhouse officers to
respond to public health
hazards that face the state and local
communities
the informationist report covered the
period of november 1st 2020 to october
30th 2021. the state readiness report on
local health office is required under
rsa 128 colon 11 to be submitted
annually to the joint legislative
committee on health and human services
we recognize representative marsh for
his support of that bill
readiness to respond to health health
require an understanding about the
various risks to community health and
the ability to train and support health
offices to address them health offices
have three primary state
statutes that provide the authority
under
rsa 128 general sanitation housing
standards under rsa 48a
and health
nuisances under 47.
main role at a health office was to
reduce the spread of environmental
health between populations thus reducing
costs illnesses suffering
health officers focus on sanitary
hazards in air water waste housing and
related nuisances
the state of new hampshire has over 306
health offices and deputy health offices
rsa 128 specifies that a health officer
is appointed by each town
most of the health offices especially in
the smaller towns work on a part-time or
voluntary basis
some of the health offices participated
in 13 regional health networks
throughout the state helping with
emergency preparedness and the response
to health threats
through the bill a training course for
health offices is required
and is currently under development the
department of health and human services
is currently working with a vendor to
create
an online learning system so health
officers can attend virtually from
anywhere in the state
dhhs will
schedule a training once the training
platform is completed
expected training start in may of june
of 2022
new hampshire health offices association
also conducts full-day training
workshops for health offices in the
spring and fall of each year a example
of this training was in the spring of
last year dr benjamin chan presented on
the covet 19
at the that workshop
additional semi-annual workshops for
health office association provided
support
to the local health officers throughout
the year
the officers uh
the new hampshire health officers
association are
wayne whitford president brian lockhart
vice president denise horwick's
secretary in the
denis de beau treasurer
public health
threats facing health offices
communicable diseases the pandemic has
demonstrated the importance of the role
of health officers to assess and improve
conditions and reduce the spread of
germs via surface food and water in
indoor air between people
prior to the pandemic
there was limited collaboration between
the state and local health offices in
managing the transmission of droplet
bond diseases like covert and influenza
nhoa
recommends that health
that the dhhs work in improving
communication training and support for
the health offices of cities and towns
another issue with hoarding and
possessions sanitary problem from
boarding of materials and animals is
growing in the state
and
we recommend that this committee take a
study of hoarding and determine the
extent and the impacts
of local health officials to respond to
these challenging situations
rental health is another issue
the residents in housing units result
from the inability of a landlord to
maintain maintain
the property from any other tenants who
may keep an unit in unsanitary
conditions health offices are often
limited by training testing skill
equipment to resolve these health
hazards and disputes
the association recommends the committee
review current laws including rsa 48a to
determine if adequate support to health
offices and their ability to assess and
resolve the rental housing units
workforce training
in the past health officers were
frequently appointed to their jobs by a
municipality with no public training or
background experience
this change with rsa 20 128 colon 11
specified minimum training health for
health offices and established a vehicle
for new health officer training as well
as continuing education let me interrupt
you there if if they are not required to
have
such training although that is being
addressed
should they not be required to have in
there i'm going to date myself rolodex
the names of people in the immediate
area who are so if a local health
officer sees a problem knows it's a
problem doesn't have the training to get
in investigate it more fully there's
somebody immediately that they can go to
who will come in and do what's necessary
yes mr chairman
we have a list of health offices
throughout the area many who have years
of experience
there's a mentoring program which we can
call on to assist a health officer who
may need training in a particular side
project and of course dhhs is there to
support them
let me give you a follow-up
is there a mechanism whereby if a health
officer realizes he or she is in over
his or her head
and doesn't ask for help it just moves
on is there a mechanism to say sorry you
can't do that
at this point there's no mechanism in
place thank you
um
that really concludes my presentation
thank you for your time and attention to
the important awareness
of public health
and we also have our members of dhsa
dhhs here to address
good morning representative pearson and
members of the committee um we were
going to do a presentation from the
department today dhhs i'm matthew kaling
um i'm a program manager with the within
public health and we did have a response
talking about solutions to the four
major problems you just heard about but
the proposal is that seeing where we've
got limited limited time and many
important things to talk today talk
about today we could defer our
presentation um off to april and happily
come back and address those uh some of
the solutions and if you'd like to ask
questions about the specific problems
and public health hazards we could
address those today with
wayne
whitford from the association
i for one would like to see solutions to
the problem and what the legislature's
role may be in solving this because i'm
rather unhappy with what i've been
hearing i'm not unhappy with you guys it
sounds like you guys are paying
attention to it but i'm unhappy that
we're not there yet
i
see our tentative schedule for april's
already pretty full
um
even though the one who makes it is a
genius at shoehorning in incredible
amounts of stuff
still is a point
uh i would be
personally happy to
uh receive at least a report by email so
i can take a look at this right away
if you could send this through
mr edwards out to all of us on this
oversight committee
that would be very helpful the report
was on readiness was delivered to the
committee today and it should be within
your packet
um it should be on the back of the
testimony that that the department dhhs
provided so we do have the report here
um
about state readiness report on local
health officers should be the lifting
and the title on the top so we do have
the reports okay there it is wow that
was quick it was it was we had someone
out earlier but i know that people are
busy and
they don't always receive these so the
report is here
and wayne has described the four major
um
public health threats that are
challenging for health officers to
respond to okay i've got the threats i'm
as far along as that where's the
solution
well the solutions are primarily in our
testimony but there are a couple of
recommendations i think that wayne put
forward which you're
welcome to discuss again
i would like that fleshed out i would
like each one of these four
uh problems fleshed out with
doable solutions that we can look at
with you
so
i would suggest come up with that report
and send that to us i don't know when we
can talk to you face to face
but at least send us
answers to the four questions we do
within our testimony today from dhh have
have some of those answers for you okay
all right some of those is good good
we'd like that i'd like that fleshed out
more fully okay so for today you'd like
us to go back and work on those the the
report for this year is done uh-huh but
we'll we can come forward with a
supplementary report which can report on
solutions
that's what i'm looking for solutions
also how do i get a list
of the public health officer for each of
the towns in my district
hi
senator chairman pearson um so all of
the health officers are listed on the
department's health officer liaison
website there is a pdf that is updated
every month on the health officers that
have been appointed throughout the state
we can also send you that pdf version
via email if you would like
again maybe that could be sent out to
everybody here some of us are
not exactly luddites but we get their
point you know we can do that for you
thank you
representative edwards i i
uh my english teacher
would point out to me
that
where you've listed your four threats uh
transmission hoarding rental housing
workforce
when you summarize them in the
conclusion you're summarizing a
different four
so the conclusion doesn't match the body
and that's just an editorial comment
if somebody just reads the conclusion
they'd miss what you really think
anyone else
representative marsh
yes thank thank you chairman pearson i i
went as probably the only person uh in
this committee who's served as a health
officer for 20 years i i think that you
need to recognize
that
department of health has
come a very long way
the institution of training for health
officers is a brand new thing we just
passed house bill
79 last year the department is
implementing that and i think having
training for health officers is going to
address a great deal of the concerns
that that you have heard i also want and
i'd like sophia to to elaborate upon
this they do a wonderful job at the
department both of making sure that the
health officers know what their
responsibilities are and what the limits
of their responsibilities are the health
officers are not appointed by the towns
they're nominated by the towns they're
appointed by the commissioner and they
serve at her pleasure so if there is a
rogue person the commissioner can
address that um and i i think a great
deal of work has been done to to
address many of these problems before
they were even brought up and i would
like to give sophia a chance to explain
a little bit more of what she and matt
have been doing in the department to
address these issues so thank you for
that and before she does i would like to
clarify that i'm going i'm
forward-looking i do appreciate and am
somewhat aware
of the progress that has been made so
sofia yes
thank you representative marsh
so the health officer liaison program at
the department currently has one
part-time staff person
and we are funded by the cdc block grant
our program is responsible for managing
a private list serve so that is how we
communicate with all over 300 health
officers across the state we also
maintain a training manual
for health officers to help them
understand how to address different
sanitary conditions or concerns that may
arise in their town
example chapters of that health officer
manual include septic issues
sanitary conditions and day cares
water quality issues all of these types
of health concerns are addressed by the
local health officer
in addition to that manual and the list
serve messages we also engage in
generally two to four trainings every
year on specific issues that the health
officer would address
so we provide up until this point with
covid those trainings have been executed
via a
online platform but the new hampshire
health officer association also provides
two trainings a year
and they have been in person up until
this point for health officers again to
understand what their responsibilities
are under the law as well as how to
perform those inspections and respond to
the different environmental health
threats that they may
come in contact with in their town
wonderful
thank you thank you any other questions
comments
seeing none thank you so much and
looking forward to getting that stuff in
the mail
or the email yes i can do email actually
yes
i know you do
so does representative soloway
next to the last stop is house bill
127 from 2019 state office of rural
health annual reports
alisa drasma did i get that right
okay
well i do
elisa drezba administrator rural health
and primary care section and that's this
report here yes it is division of public
health services it's 44 pages long
um
so i'm going to get i'm going to give
you the highlights you're not going to
read it i'm not going to read it but the
nice thing about it being 44 pages long
means that we're doing our job and we're
doing our job even more efficiently
because every year we have more data to
share with you and more information that
we feel is actionable both on a rural
health side and also on a workforce data
collection side just statutorily they
move those together so we cover both of
those items under one report
so all of the measures in our report are
focused on
assessing access delivery and
utilization of primary care specifically
and we also have some demographic data
that highlights population risk factors
that are associated with access to
primary care
all of the health status indicators in
the report are the ones where there is a
statistical difference between rural and
non-rural new hampshire as a highlight
that full list is an appendix a of the
report
a lot of the visualizations that are now
available in the report came from
upgrades to the dhh data dashboard there
is a rurality filter now available
where the data is applicable and it has
a color-coded significance that
immediately tells you if rural or
non-rural is statistically different for
that outcome indicator and also there
are numbers on a chart that drill down
by public health region to show if there
are any outlay outliers by public health
region for both the rural and non-rural
status
so i'm gonna breeze
real residents more likely to be older
disabled low-income uninsured and
veterans than non-rural residents this
is consistent year to year as far as
population factors
the rates were highest in the north
country for all of these measures with
the exception of senior age and
percentage of uninsured in which carroll
county rates were the highest
the rate of non-fluent english speakers
is twice as high in non-rural new
hampshire than in rural
moving on to barriers of care
we show geographic disparities when we
look at travel so what we do is we look
at the percentage of the
visits that people took that took them
over 30 minutes to access primary care
as well as their median travel distance
and also whether or not they indicate
that they have a personal doctor or
health care provider
and so
no surprise i'm sure to all of you the
travel times for rural populations
are uh
of them are longer than a non-rural
population to access that care
the ones that really stand out are
winnipesaukee and carroll county public
health regions they have the highest
rate
and the lowest
travel rates are greater manchester and
greater nashua
the percentage of new hampshire's rural
population that indicate they don't have
a personal doctor or health care
provider jumped by one-third between um
so from 13.7 percent to 18.1 percent
between last year's report and this
year's report
for substance use and mental health care
we
look at emergency department visits for
this and we look at the rates
of people using those emergency
departments for substance use or mental
health
around alcohol and drug related
emergency department visits
there is no geographic disparity between
rural and non-rural
on this particular rate which is
different from last year but when we
look at that there are some public
health regions that stand out as being
statistic statistically worse off and
that would be winnipesaukee and greater
manchester
and then conflicting with the trend of
improved rates of substance related and
self-harm ed visits
non-rural suicide rates actually jumped
up in rate
for maternal
health we look at indicators around
whether there was no or late prenatal
care whether there was a post-term
delivery so 42 plus weeks or whether
people indicated they were smoking
during their pregnancy
there's no significant disparity um for
post
post-term delivery um and also for no or
late prenatal care rates except for in
winnipesaukee
um but also rural residents continue to
have higher rates of smoking during
pregnancy than their non-rural
counterparts and i can tell you that
this every single year we see that
particular indicator stand out and do
you cross that with level of education
that stat
we do not for this report but we work
with our tobacco program on talking
about some of the factors that that may
be driving what we're seeing as far as
our outcomes okay thank you
for preventive care
we look at things like colonoscopy and
mammography
um so this is one place where
winnipesaukee even though they don't do
well on some of those other things that
i've shared with you they do
very well they actually have the second
highest rate of mammography in the
entire state which is only one percent
lower than the upper valley
which is where dartmouth-hitchcock
medical center sits
the medical check-up rates increase for
both rural and non-rural populations but
it's still higher and non-rural
and there's no geographic disparity of
dental visits this year which we usually
do find that the non-uh the rural areas
have fewer dental visits than non-rural
but that is because the non-rural
residents are actually reporting more
that they don't visit the dentist so
it's evening out
but not in a good way not in an
increased access way
and then we have a section on outcomes
and these are prevention quality
indicators which used to be called
ambulatory care sensitive conditions so
there they would be reasons that people
would visit an emergency department
where the condition could have managed
been managed in primary care but became
a medical emergency and so we do look at
those
and
we have consistently found that the
chronic disease composite and the
overall composite for these pqis was
statistically higher in non-rural new
hampshire compared to rural
so in other words non-rural residents
were more likely to be admitted to the
hospital for preventable medical
complications than their rural
counterparts
why do you think that is
i i don't know exactly
i think what that indicates is that they
they may be being managed perhaps more
so even though they're traveling greater
distances and they may not have a
personal doctor the ones that do have
that relationship and are doing that
access are taking advantage of things
like chronic disease care management
models and that's actually managing
their conditions where they are not
showing up in the rural emergency
departments
for the late stage proportional rate of
breast cancer and rural is significantly
greater than in non-rural suggesting a
disparity in access and utilization of
primary care between the geographic
regions and there's no statistical
difference between the rates of death
from all causes by morality
a few of those public health regions do
stand out as having considerably higher
age-adjusted rates and those would be
the highest in winnipesaukee north
country and strafford county
so that's the rural data now we're
moving on to health work first data
collection
you can see all of that information we
have
since the first time we started
reporting to you in 2019 we have moved
from talking about the data collection
efforts which are done through the
renewal of licensing through the boards
as a part of a survey or opt-out that
are required as part of the renewal
we've moved on from talking about
implementation
to response rates to actually being able
to tell you what that data is showing so
on our web page we have each of the data
reports available by provider type that
go into all of the different sort of
nuances of what we're seeing based on
the data we collect
and then for this report what we do is
we roll up a few items that we think are
particularly significant and what we
also try to do is cluster together the
primary care providers so those are the
primary care physicians the primary care
physician assistants and the nurse
practitioners practitioners who provide
primary care together and look at them
and look at differences between each of
those provider types and also by
rurality and then we do the same thing
on the mental health side we put the
psychiatrists together with the mental
health practitioners the sud providers
and the men and the psychologists and we
roll those up and look at their
differences as well and we also look at
their reality so what we're looking for
in those aspects are differences in
demographics
training
age groups
whether or not they had a tie to new
hampshire that may indicate why they're
practicing here training schooling
and then also
some retention indicators about where
where they think they're going to be in
the next five years
and then we provide all of that
information so that people can take
action around those various items
so one of the new things that we started
doing was trying to gauge the net change
of provider supply based on the
licensing lists
and so in here is a chart that covers
the number of license renewals that
we've had each year as an indicator of
whether or not our supply is going up or
down we're going to need to end this
because i have one more group to come in
sure so it it is all in there i am happy
to answer any questions like i said we
have all of our reports available as
well
and if you have any particular areas of
interest we can definitely address those
as well i have one question it has to do
with the trends
rural to non-rural
i'm assuming that rural population is
declining is that correct that is
correct is the rate of decline static
increasing or lessening
that's a great question i don't know
that yet so that would be based on the
census data that's just becoming
available and that's not quite available
to us in our dashboard but it's
definitely something that we can look
into it would be good and second
question is
with the
better availability of telehealth
medicine
are some of the
rural parts of the state
that
present numbers
higher
not having a pcp
is that moderating
we do not have data from the pandemic
yet okay um and actually
the way that we collect this is capacity
and in order to assess that we would
either need to wait for some sort of
outcome issue or another data collection
effort where people report access
but we can also look at that utilization
through claims data
how often do your people just drive
around and talk with doctors because you
know data's great so is boots on the
ground sure so we have a team that
focuses on critical access hospitals i
run a network connected to the rural
health clinics specifically we also work
with primary care and we um i vice chair
commission that meets every month on the
interdisciplinary primary care workforce
we've been meeting since 2008 we just
met yesterday and that that is comprised
of a number of different provider types
as well as providers themselves
training and other folks and we just
presented actually danielle hernandez
from my office presented some reports
yesterday as well and we had a very
robust conversation about
making sure that we
continue to find out what's happening on
the ground from providers because that
that really does help us shape our other
workforce development programs
that's a wonderful intersection when
eyes on the situation and data in the
computer can intersect it's my favorite
thing to do is to get out there
i like raising basset hounds any
questions representative nelson thank
you mr chairman thank you for taking my
question i live in carroll county
southern carroll county
and we have several
good hospitals and services over in
wolfeboro
but a lot of my residents in our area go
south
to stratford county
and quite frankly
people are annoyed there because where
they go they've closed the clinic that
they had in carroll county
their doctors have lost
i think it's like 18 doctors have left
and it's all because of new ownership
and how they're being treated and so
when you look at your statistics the
people in my region who use those
services
either they've given up
and they don't go as often hopefully
they've gone over to wolfeboro where
they do a great job but
they're very upset and how
these types of hospitals can
with significant turnover
i don't know i can't believe somebody
doesn't oversee it but that's not your
issue thank you
we do have some workforce recruitment
and retention programs that i'm happy to
come back and tell you about as well to
hopefully be able to stabilize some of
those relationships and those providers
thank you the commissioner alluded to
that a couple of meetings ago that's a
wonderful helpful thing
especially when it kicks in
representative murphy
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question one of the questions
i would have and i was looking through
the rural data specifically
is do you have or could you put together
something similar to food insecurity
deserts a health care does it
so if you saw it on a map to say
the the paucity of primary care in
colebrook has just gone down immensely
so it'd be in a sense a visual to see a
healthcare desert
shown you know geographically throughout
the state so we could do that two ways
one of the ways is by rolling up the
fte so the full-time equivalents and
looking at that but also i'm doing
another project under our federal grant
where we're we are looking at a
bunch of different data to look at that
and what we want to do is identify where
healthcare should be not where it
already exists so that that is in
progress
thank you so much for your presentation
i've never seen a 44-page document
so
wonderfully thank you thank you
and the last presentation advisory
council on child care annual report
marianne barta chair and deborah nelson
bureau chief child development and head
start collaboration division of economic
and housing stability of the new
hampshire department of health and human
services does that all fit on one
business card
mr chairman i just want to let you know
that i am diane chase i'm the assistant
bureau chief in the bureau of child
development diane chase assistant bureau
chief okay and i'm here on behalf of
deborah nelson
thank you
hi and i am marianne barter and i can be
very brief the child care advisory
council is made up of stakeholders and
entirely volunteer child care providers
who look to the lens of keeping child
care affordable and accessible in new
hampshire and so what we do is we
are tasked with looking at child care
licensing rules dhhs rules things that
might be barriers to creating child care
businesses or keeping your child care
business going in in new hampshire we
also want to make sure that all children
can afford safe affordable child care
and that's not just something that can
be accessed by accessed by people with
strong economic resources
so we've been very busy during the
pandemic i think that child care is like
a really great bridge and you don't
notice a really great bridge when you're
driving over it until it crumbles and
that's sort of where we have been
and we've been very busy for the last
couple of years trying to build the
infrastructure of child care in the
state with our partners at dhhs
we are part of the b8 quadrant of the
council for thriving children we're part
of the workforce development groups
we had a subcommittee that looked at
child care licensing regulations
and
we've had countless meetings
every other week we meet with over 100
stakeholders and child care providers to
find out what is happening in the field
ultimately i guess
ultimately the field is in trouble child
care in new hampshire is in trouble um
programs have closed since the beginning
of the pandemic and more than that rooms
have closed so you may have your
neighborhood child care facility that is
still open and operating but it has half
the capacity that it used to in the past
really because of workforce and we've
had several other other groups present
today about their workforce shortages
and i guess my plea would be that if we
can solve the child care workforce
shortage we're going to solve an awful
lot of those child those workforce
shortages too
so um we really need we need help with
infrastructure but we also need
immediate help to keep reta to retain
our workforce and to recruit others to
our workforce
i'm happy to take any questions
is there
recruitment
or describe the recruitment to get child
care workers
right now there's almost none so so it's
individual businesses attempting to hire
we are working with our dhh partners to
create a
flow into the field which used to be the
high school cte programs when they moved
to k-12 prioritizing k-12
it killed ch early childhood and the
effect on our field has been truly
detrimental and we've noticed it
accelerating over the past six years
so at this point we're rebuilding what
what was taken apart
um i am worried that
although i'm really excited about some
of the
i mean some of the stuff that's
happening is amazing the teach program
the apprentice program but it will take
years to really rebuild that
infrastructure and we it we're desperate
to retain the staff that we have at this
point
um i just wanted to let you know
that uh presently with the um arpa
uh what are called discretionary funds
um we are launching actually it's
starting next week um
a series of public service announcements
specifically targeted to the early
childhood in what we call out of school
time workforce which is after school and
before school
that'll be linked with what's called a
vanity url
into a job listing site um all of the
providers will be getting actually a
letter on monday morning about how to
put their listings
as well as we have a live person who
will be able to answer our phone so if
you have an interest in any aspect of
working in the child care field they'll
be able to direct you
um and we're in addition putting
together um in partnership with ccac um
what's called
a traveling recruiting booth
some of them are virtual some of them
are live
some of them were piloted for example
last year at the dear field fair now
that things are opening up you know
you're walking by you capture the
audience
and talk to them about the different
opportunities and the career lattices
within the child care field as well as
promoting the programs that we have
which are apprenticeship internships
it's a it's a low barrier entry industry
in some ways but it also has amazing
career opportunities and so that's kind
of the picture that we're trying to
um
to share is that
you may be a retiree and you want to do
it or you may be a high school student
and you're going to um try out the field
and find a career place
and diane is absolutely right i we have
to change the narrative that early
childhood education is a dead-end career
where you're going to go and you're
going to make 12 an hour for the rest of
your life that is no longer the reality
of our field and it's going to take i
think
a paradigm shift of all of us to
understand that this field has changed
and we have responded to the low wages
we've responded to the educational
requirements and there are systems in
place to really build and grow our
workforce we just need to bring them to
us first and it's truly catastrophic
though it is i mean i could use i'm the
executive director of a child care
facility and
i'm licensed for 305 spaces but my
capacity due to my staffing is 137.
that has a huge impact on me it has a
huge impact on the families in concord
new hampshire that have been depending
on those 305 spaces for a very long time
so it is it is we are at a catastrophic
loss right now
my assumption is in the
old days
the chief requirement
um
to do child care is you didn't have a
prison record and you loved kids
yes and i'm now assuming that the
there's a little bit more training along
the way am i
inferring correctly that there's entry
level and then after some further
training and years of experience or
months of experience there's a another
certificate that you can get which
presumably means a little bit more money
and responsibility and a little bit more
so there's la there's a ladder
absolutely there is a ladder and i think
that there's misconceptions about the
fact that um
you know you're
that you'll never be able to change your
position that your job will be entirely
working with toddlers for the rest of
your career there there is a ladder
there's room for change and there's room
for growth i mean i i think that
the future of early childhood education
is astounding you know there's attention
on this on the federal level there's
never been before
i'm very worried about the next year the
next year is what i'm worried about
because as we continue to lose people we
cannot replace them if it takes eight
months to replace a preschool teacher
and you know that you are not replacing
them with nearly as good a preschool
teacher is left those are potentially 12
to 24 families that have been impacted
by that loss for an extended period of
time so the child care advisory council
is very very worried about short-term
investment
as fast as we can get it out there to
make sure that the people who are
hanging in there in the field hang in
just a little bit longer until we can
make it significantly better for
everybody
who does the education if there's
various steps where does one go yeah um
oh what what are the steps i mean
there's different positions you can
start an early childhood education with
just a love of children um no that's not
my question you're at this level
and you want to go up the ladder and get
a higher certificate better title
who teaches you to do that nhti or any
of the community
community college systems or the
university system
and dhhs has tremendous financial
support for the field so if you are just
starting out and you want to advance you
can take a class for free they will pay
for it
there's usually several offerings so the
supports are there we just need to in
the short term draw and retain as many
people as possible so they can take
advantage of these supports and you've
got some public service announcements
rolling out to let everybody know what
you just told me that i didn't know
until you just told me
yeah and hopefully they will happen fast
they've been in the works since the fall
okay and so like anything else during
the pandemic everything takes forever so
we are truly hoping they will roll out
soon
any questions to the presenter
representative mcmahon
thank you mr chairman uh ms barter uh
specific to the letter you provided
both your profession was provided uh
what's the status of the pilot program
to incentivize incentivize businesses
to support
education for their
employees children
i think it
changes business by business do you have
a pilot going yes we haven't uh we've
just in the preliminary planning stages
on how to implement that um and the
the the plan of attack if you will is to
we're going to initially launch a um an
employer survey to to do a query and
that should go in the next couple weeks
to every employer into the in the state
to say what are you doing around child
care as well as ask their employees
and then from there craft the um an
incentive um pilot to find out what are
working what things are working we have
everything in this state we have some
amazing models
um we have a an employer for example
that just bought a multi-million dollar
building that he's putting a child care
center in and he only needs 20 spaces
for his people but he's doing it for the
community um and then we have people
that are specifically have come to us
and said talk to us about job sharing
and how do we structure this in our
company so that we can have working
parents and um and they can job share
and watch each other's children how do
we set that up
so what we want to do is we find out
what models work
and then be turn around and be able to
put our funds and our support in those
appropriate areas
then one follow-up follow-up follow-up
uh for either one of you ladies uh
specific to the fact that the industrial
arts were not responding
to training on the front end
you have recommendations that's part of
the as an offset of the pilot program to
bring that
back
uh to at the height i'm looking at the
high school level for for a job track
within those who have industrial uh the
industrial arts curriculum vitae
what's your thoughts on that
um we do so that is the absolute best
way to get people interested in our
field and to draw people who are born to
do this work into the work so absolutely
our cte partners are our most important
resource we're barely starting that work
now so we won't see the kind of the
fruits of this labor for three four
maybe five years because these kit we
have to develop the programs we have to
get the kids interested and then they
have to be able to get through the two
years of the program so that is a
long-term strategy that is going to be
game changing in the long term
and just one more clarification
clarification
as again specific to what you wrote on
where in 2015 the career pipeline was
quote dismantled
uh
to get things done while we're young how
quickly can this
be
how quickly could that be accelerated
over and above what you're already doing
um
certainly so there is a senate bill that
um has been amended recently 446 where
senator bradley has
tasked dhhs to work with child care
advisory council to
look at some of these things and get
them done quickly
i'm being optimistic about four years i
think it really these sort of programs
when you're trying to embed them in high
schools especially programs that had
them yanked away from them in 2015 it
will it's going to take time it will
take time to do it so in a perfect world
we'll get the programs up and running
within the next couple of years and then
we'll start seeing graduates from them
but i think that that's i would love to
be
optimist more optimistic than that about
it but i just can't be i think it will
take that long thank you very much thank
you just clarify the term dismantled
what they did was they they turned
around and they didn't they didn't stop
recommending early childhood as a field
what they did is they shut down the
child care centers
shifted their resources to expanding
programming to include education careers
from what i say birth through high
school and so as a result where we had a
real clear pipeline
that pipeline became very muddied um you
know you didn't have the child care
centers the kids doing the programs in
the school and going directly in and i
think um the wonderful part about it is
that the the high school folks that
we've met with are totally on board this
isn't we're not fighting any kind of
battle to do it um they're interested in
it
and i think they're i think
for big programs sure it'll take a
period of time but i think we're i think
we'll have an opportunity to get some of
those young people
internship and existing programs
um faster i'm hoping i'm i'm more
optimistic yeah i
[Laughter]
and it felt like a dismantling i mean i
had i run a large program in concord i
used to have 50 high school children in
my building every friday and now
i'm lucky if i can hire a kid after
school
thank you so much and with this we close
today's meeting of
oversight but not until
we have heard from the distinguished
senator
um senate bill 446 was mentioned
uh that uh the changes to that to talk
about arpa funds
the department is the one that needs to
put the plan together to go forward in
our funds and i'm sure that mr williams
can give us an update on that
and mr chair
not on that issue but on the committee i
have noted the attendance here in the
last half hour
something's got to change if we're
having these people you know take time
out of their day
to come before us we need to be here or
we need to change something because this
just isn't working senator i have two
people on my hit list written down
that i will attend to thank you so much
having heard
from the distinguished senator we are
now finished thank you for coming
yes i got a couple
you